la gente sale a la calle porque no tiene
otros canales de comunicar su desacuerdo
con las políticas de uno u otro gobierno
lo conocemos muy bien por las
experiencias que vivimos aquí en américa
latina'
entonces lo que está pasando en rusia en
este momento y las personas que salen a
la calle es precisamente porque quieren
expresar su desacuerdo el rechazo de las
políticas de vladimir putin ahora la
pregunta es grande hasta que realmente
hasta hasta en qué medida ellos pueden
influenciar la política de vladimir
putin yo creo que obviamente con el
régimen actual en ruso es algo que
posiblemente no va a tener un impacto
inmediato sobre la estrategia de
vladimir putin pero hay algo que me
llamó la atención o en la mañana y
seguramente va a ser
distribuido esta información por los
medios de comunicación vladimir putin
firmó una ley
y permite al estado ruso confiscar los
fondos de los funcionarios del gobierno
si los funcionarios del gobierno no
pueden justificar estos fondos qué
quiere decir esto es una medida que la
oposición rusa estaba demandando durante
tantos años y que realmente no ha
logrado hasta ahora esto significa que
realmente hay algo está pasando